çok
öp bir hikaye var
Baba Herşeyden şikayet eden oğluna
birşeyler öğretmek için önüne üç tane
malzeme koyar
o patates yumurta ve kahve ve ondan
sonra da der ki bunlar işte üçünü birer
tane kabak koy 20 dakika pişir bak
bakalım ne oluyor bak kadar 20 dakika
pişirdikten sonra da çocuğa sorar Ne
oldu çocuklar pişti bunlar yani birşey
olmadı ki belki yanlış düşünüyorsun
patates
Sertip geçtikten sonra iç yumuşadı
yumurtanın içi yumuşaktı Bu sefer o
Kaynar suyu gördükten sonra sertleşti
kahve kendi halinde hiç tadı yoktur
yenebilir durumda değildi Şimdi Suya
bütün rahiyası bıraktı bu hayat senin
altındaki suyu pişirmeye başladığı zaman
ne yapacaksın
şimdi etrafımızda Bazı insanlar vardır
öyle be çok eğlenceli dirler
Sürekli her şeye gülerler de her şey
Onlar için komik bir eğlencelidir
bazıları vardır
bir hayat onlara ne yaparsa yapsın gene
ayakta kalmayı beceren işlerde burada
örneklerini gördük
baktığınızda mesafenin favori
örneklerinden bir tanesi bu çünkü Steve
Jobs Aslında Macintosh batmaya başladı
zaman kendi yönetim kurulu tarafından
işten kovulup sonra Pixel Grup Pick sarı
Disney sattıktan sonra o batmakta olan
ve kinto şu alıp tekrar Mac haline
getirip şimdi işte dünyanın en pahalı ve
popüler bilgisayardan üreten firmayı
yapmış kişi hep bir de başka insan
tipleri de vardır öyle bugün enerji
soran diyorlar ya onlardan böyle benim
bir tane arkadaşım var Mesela bu değil
bu benim arkadaşım uygulanır Ya
ama ben böyle yarım saat yanında oturana
kadar beraber köprüye gidersiniz öyle
düşünün Şimdi ben olaylara tabi fizik
öğretmen olarak biraz daha farklı bir
açıdan bakmak istiyorum
şimdi şöyle bir şey düşünebiliriz bir
kazak kazak kırmızı renkli niye
kırmızı olduğu için hayır
o fizikte bir şeyin rengi Aslında ona
düşen ışığı yansıtması ile belli olur
Dolayısıyla bu kazak Aslında kırmızı
değil kırmızı yansıtıyor veya diğer
kazaklar baktığınızda niye diğerleri
farklı renklerde E çünkü aynı Işık
onların üzerine düşmesine rağmen Bunlar
da kendi renklerini yansıtıyorlar
şimdi günlük hayat hepimiz için üç aşağı
beş yukarı Benzer şeyleri içeri olabilir
baktığımızda sabah yani Hepimiz işte
anne babamız çoluğumuz çocuğumuz
kardeşimiz gülümseyerek bizi karşılıyor
şişede bileyim Sabah metroya binerken
arkadaki adam omuz atıyor
Ondan sonra giderken trafik işte bir
emniyet şeridinden geliyor ya bunların
hepsi bizim başımıza mı geliyor işe
yetişmek lazım yarısı yenmiş simit çay
falan her şey başımıza kötü mü geliyor
veya Sadece bizim ne geliyor
bakın benim kişisel düşüncelerinden bir
tanesi şu Bunlar hepimizin başına aşağı
yukarı baktığımızda Aslında
benzer şekilde hepimizin başına geliyor
Biz hangisini yansıtıyoruz
ve başımıza bunca olumsuz şey geldiği
zaman
bizsiz hep Gölgelerin arasında mı
kalmayı tercih edeceğiz niye gölge Çünkü
Işık yansımadığı zaman daha doğrusu
herhangi bir obje ışığı yansıtıyorsa
siyah renkli olur orası gölge kısmını
şimdi buraları geçelim bu çalışıyor mu
bilmiyorum Evet şimdi
bu çok hoşuma giden sözlerden bir tanesi
bir şeyi yapabilirim diyen kişiyle
yapamam diyen kişilerin İkisi de eşit
derecede haklıdır
Bu yüzden bu
bu
işler her zaman kolay mıydı Einstein o
efsanevi denklem işte eşittir emcek
arayıp böyle mi buldum mesela
hayatına Hep mi kolaydı Hayır her zaman
çalıştı yetenek Evet yetenek doğuştan
geliyor olabilir ama beceri saatlerce
saatlerce saatlerce çalışma sonucunda
ortaya çıkar ve az önce örneğinde gördük
zaten
Eğer
berişler sizin için kolay gidiyorsa o
zaman gelişmiyor sunuz demektir okali
kan ter gözyaşı falan diyorlar ya
gelişebilmek için işte bunlara
ihtiyacımız var Bunlar olmadan hayat çok
kolay olur hepimizin önünde
bağışla bu adamda çok kolay para
kazanıyor dediğiniz insanların olduğunu
biliyorum ama insanların kendileri
Yüzyıl önce de vardı bugün hiç birini
almıyoruz bile gerçekten çalışıp çaba
gösterip bir yere gel O insanları bugün
biliyoruz mesela çok sevdiğim
örneklerden bir tanesi 1927 soldaki
Konferansı fotoğrafını görüyorsunuz
burada zeka seviyesi böyle sıra toz
ferler de falan böyle atmosferi aşmış
vaziyette Ama bu konu burada Mesela bir
tane kadın var Madam Curie şu Einstein
iki tane sol tarafında Bu kadının hayatı
mesela zorluklarla Geçmiş bütün hayatı
ve bu konferansta Bu kadınla O çok zeki
diye gördüğümüz adamlar arkadaşlar
şurada engeller borular falan
konuşmuyorlar bilimde kadının yeri yok
diye bir de karşıdan konuşuyor
yazacaktım ama onun dışındakilerin
tamamı konuşmalar bu kadın hayatı
inanılmaz zorluklarla geçiyor ama o
yüzden Madam kilo zaten
Oyüzden tekrar söylemek istiyorum bir
şeyi yapabilirim diyen kişiyle yapamam
diyen kişilerin ikisi de ve eşit
derecede haklıdır siz hangisini
seçeceksiniz teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]